hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you that's right
I'm not yelling it I'm [ __ ] up my
voice doing that every goddamn week I'm
starting to drink throat koti I need to
take care of myself in these next this
next chapter as I peel off another layer
of the onion whatever stupid artistry
thing I've just decided you know few
people in my life you know I'm kind of
seeing it I'm seeing it I'm seeing what
living a certain lifestyle leads to and
I'm like you know what I need to clean
up my act a little bit all right
it's time to grow up and so one of the
first things I'm going to do I'm not
cutting out the booze what I'm just
gonna stop yelling I'm checking in on
you you know it's baby steps you know
and I'll gradually work towards laying
off the heroin you know I like it it
helps me helps me go to sleep you know
the amount of times that I always want
to take a nap when I'm standing up
outside in public and I just can't do it
because my mind just won't shut off you
know that's that's when the heroin comes
in that's when it comes into play you're
gonna have listened to my phone
dingdong and because I got a phone call
coming up and I don't miss it here um
anyways let me see here uh Jesus now I'm
going to be looking at text message
message messages messages while I'm
trying to do this podcast this is really
going to [ __ ] with my a dee dee here
how's your week going I'm gonna tell you
something right oh but Oh Billy booze
bag all right I had I had family in from
back east some of you guys guessed the
movie by the way it's something you do
with the car can't figure it out now I
can't help you I mean what I love is now
everybody knows what the movie is but
they're still going to tech treat me
like digit you know the long long long
trailer starring Lucille Ball
why don't you guys ask me if it's every
other movie that you can do with the car
other than the one you know it is how
about that how about switching it up a
little bit is it Herbie goes to Monte
Carlo
you know I realize all these years I've
been using that as a reference like
because it's the one of the first or
second movie I saw suffer love of Benjy
then I saw Herbie goes to Monte Carlo
and my mother was just like my mother
told me you know I did just those kids
movies were stupid I wasn't gonna take
it anymore those you know basically
there wasn't anything there for her and
she just was looking at like you know
there's really nothing here for these
kids it's a [ __ ] talking car it's a
talking dog you know how long are we
going to keep the lie going alright the
fat [ __ ] doesn't come down the chimney
dogs don't talk
and the VW Beetle it's a it's a
economical car but you know at the end
of the day it's not respected so that's
it let's go see stripes um anyways uh
completely forgot what the [ __ ] I was
going to say there how the [ __ ] did I
get to that I have no idea do I need to
go on bring money to play some brain
games sell what is what the [ __ ] was Oh
eat more healthy I don't know what is
all yet so magma but the family back
east I got it I got it Rebecca
right give me those outtakes on Casey
Kasem when he flips out screaming yell
now god damn it I'm not [ __ ] reading
about a [ __ ] dog died you know this
is basically like those outtakes except
you die I don't edit them up and I also
don't have his iconic success yeah other
than that I think it's the exact same
thing but anyways I have family coming
fee and we kill me in Puglia Keys twice
in this past month and I had to take him
out to the spots we had to drink a
little toast for the little one little
Nene dude she's laughing her ass off now
it's the greatest thing it's the
greatest thing ever could not be in a
joint more in its tunes first and for
the first time in my life I'm someone
can actually look at me and say Happy
Father's Day right and I don't have to
be like oh my god in what comedy club
did you work
[Laughter]
how old is it um anyways no I was never
like that on the road I was a good boy
sort of I had my moments anyways plowing
ahead here so because they came in I
kind of got off my diet I was still
doing the cardio every day so I stepped
on the scale and the unacceptable second
number in my world is eight okay if it's
ever a nine I'm telling you right now
I'm going to jump off a [ __ ] building
I won't do that
I'll just buy really comfortable I'll
keep wearing the golf clothes that I
wear they'll just get bigger you know
let's get into the John Daly life
so uh I'm back on it I'm back on it
jumped on the scale today one seventy
eight point eight still unacceptable I
have been having the worst [ __ ] time
trying to get down to my fighting weight
I wanted to be 172 by my birthday my
49th the end of the 40's wrapping it up
if I was a professional athlete I would
be ten years retired unless I was Tom
Brady with my sinewy muscles or whatever
the [ __ ] he's doing with his spongy
muscles um I don't know what he's doing
sorry I'm drinking the throat coat of
Jesus bill you're just annoying on so
many different levels today I up I
apologize um so anyways I'm just I'm
going to try to just lay off the booze
for a little bit I'm going to San
Francisco this weekend and uh I'm
working with [ __ ] my Dino my Dean
Martin Joe DeRosa okay so that's going
to be that's going to be a mulligan that
night Joe my friendship with Joe DeRosa
in his friendship with me is one of the
great friendships in show business
history and it's all it's all alcohol
filled you know I don't think we've ever
hung around each other sober and I don't
think that I got to get him on the
podcast I really got to get all [ __ ]
Joe DeRosa whatever his background is
Egyptian Italian he doesn't know that
man was left
doorstep of a funny bone way back in
I believe he showed up out of nowhere a
baby nobody wanted he came out of the
womb already wearing those dark framed
glasses on that set that said many ways
plow ahead I'm sure I'm gonna hear about
that from Oh Joey um I'm guessing two
drinks in they do there was something I
want to talk to you about it's I know
you were just joking but you know to
bring that up it's really um [ __ ] him he
trashed my dog on stage
oh that's coming out fourth drinking I'm
trying to guess what the arguments going
to come from this weekend why drink with
Joe
we really don't argue anymore once I
discovered fair enough you know I grew
up a little bit
II grew up a little bit and that's all
we do we start to argue and then one of
us just goes hey fair enough we laugh
and it just diffuses everything fair
enough fair enough can stop wars you're
I mean this is our borderline now we
think it's that hey fair enough fair
enough
I understand why you would think that
but I mean you know fair enough well are
you gonna give it to us lawyer yeah I
didn't say that
well then I'm gonna [ __ ] start
shooting I think fair enough yeah that's
what you feel you need to do it just
diffuses the other guy and the other
guys standing there going like no you're
supposed to you supposed to get mad then
you get mad and I get mad and then I lie
to my people you love your people we
humanize each other then we start
shooting stop saying fair enough all
right fair enough um anyways anybody
watch the the Penguins versus the
[ __ ] Predators I'll tell you
something about these teeth these
penguins from Pittsburgh is they know
how to [ __ ] win a goddamn series
Jesus Christ the Predators in an o2 hole
for those of you bad at math when it's
best four out of seven you're down Oh -
that means you have to win four
the next five oh the coach isn't going
to tell you that what's he going to say
all right guys all right boys we gotta
take what gave it time okay these guys
cross the hall in that locker up there
they put that skates on one boot at a
time okay we got to start winning the
battles take it one period of time um
dude they are beating this [ __ ] on a
Sidney Crosby this playoff series this
playoff justice this playoff run I don't
know what he did to the refs but they
had done protecting that guy they're
slashing I'm they're hooking him they're
[ __ ] hitting them in the head
anything that they can do um I don't
know I I think that they they they
should have brought a goon up or
something somebody to do something I
don't know but anyways how about [ __ ]
Malkin's goal absolute [ __ ]
you know and I know that they pulled old
pitot tube there whatever his [ __ ]
name is for some reason I can't remember
his goddamn name Peck arena tails his
name uh Jesus I can't [ __ ] I came
up with some about a dick is the
president I [ __ ] watched every game
and I still can't remember his name
the [ __ ] just knew he's a tech arena
was that the guy from San Jose was he on
San Jose then he went to Nashville you
know once I stopped collecting cards you
know and I turned to scotch I just never
been able to I've never been able to
handle the names anymore but anyways I
don't give a [ __ ] who you are Ken Dryden
Patrick wah Terry sawchuck nobody stops
that [ __ ] puck that was an absolute
filthy filthy [ __ ] goal so my
prediction way back in the day what did
I say what did I say before I
flip-flopped and said ottawa's going to
was going to win Game seven before I did
that I said the Penguins were going to
win the whole thing
so when it happens I'm gonna ignore the
fact that I thought Ottawa was going to
come back and win game seven because I
was
questioning the goaltending in
Pittsburgh I'm going to ignore all of
that and I'm going to pull up all
Virginie and say dude what did I say
dude I called it just out of uh you know
jealousy I want to I want to see the
Predators tie up to series not jealousy
just out of like selfishness I want to
see the the NHL season go as many games
as possible but though I thought you
right now the way the Penguins are
playing I mean I don't even see this
ball back to Pittsburgh uh we'll see
something incredible has - how about - I
don't know who [ __ ] shot the goal that
baby face kid there I mean I that was
like the puck had eyes it like there was
one little [ __ ] just puck sized space
for a split second between ol uh
Pecha penis there whatever his name is
it just opened up for half a second the
puck literally turned sideways like some
matrix [ __ ] and went in the I remember
when I when I saw it Labs I kind of [ __ ]
did that go in I don't know man I'll
tell you the hockey gods are smiling
down in Pittsburgh right now um who
knows we'll see what sort of home home
ice advantage they have but and also the
NBA playoffs
not playoffs the final starts tonight is
that the NBA Finals and the Stanley Cup
final or is it Stanley Cup Finals in the
NBA final I think it's the NBA Finals
every time I say something stupid my
phone rings that's it right there does a
little ping alright I have a call here
in [ __ ] uh let's see ten minutes ten
minutes so I'm gonna have to hit pause
here it's not gonna matter to you guys
because I'll just pick it up you know
they'll give me ten minutes of silence
like I'm trying to do some artsy that
starts tonight I don't know I don't have
a feeling on this one I want the
Cavaliers to win I want the Cavaliers to
win because I still feel like they don't
get their respect people aren't talking
about them like that the defending like
they are the defending NBA champions and
it's because Durant
went to the Warriors I think that that's
why nobody seems to be able to talk
about it you know what I mean just to be
able to see like hey not for nothing
these guys beat those other guys last
year so I hope they keep disrespecting
them because I always root against the
pylon team you know I even did it with
the Red Sox in 2007 i I just I don't
think I watched the World Series I mean
obviously I was happy that we won
obviously I'd rather see us win than the
[ __ ] Colorado Rockies but I was just
like this is that's not competition you
know having said that having said that
when the when the base when the
basketball in hockey season ends okay
I'm getting the MLB package and I'm
watching my 210 million dollar Red Sox
who are in second place three games
behind the evil empire that has nothing
but their own homegrown talent and I'm
gonna watch that collision course and
see how that goes I've learned this is
what you have to do if you're a sports
fan with some family back east is the
baseball in such a great sport but the
problem is is the first almost the first
half of the season is the most exciting
time in basketball and hockey and your
emotions as a fan are so heightened even
if your team is out of it just to watch
you know there's always something great
happens in the in the final unless you
know the [ __ ] ref called 38 fouls on
one team and 15 on the other then it
sucks letting it go and then all of a
sudden it's over and then you're
settling in just a bit outside on a
beautiful day for a ball game I'll say
his on-base percentage is 645 and he's
really seeing the ball right now I kept
you played the game what was it like
when you just down when you hit his own
like this well I'll tell you you know
when you hit a zone like this I mean
that ball I mean your eyes are as big as
Christmas and that you're having it's
just it's like you can't you just stick
into bed out there and the balls going
where it wants to go but you know and
what do you well how do you tell you try
- how do you try to stay in that zone
how you try to try to keep it go well
you know it's one of those things you
can't control you just you learn this
yes you're mature as a player - just try
to enjoy those moments and well you know
you hope it goes as long as you can but
uh
dutchy it is going to swing back to the
other way and you just hope that that's
is you know that the slump doesn't last
as long so you know you can keep your
house in that gold-digging [ __ ] that
you met in Tulsa when you're coming up
in triple-a that you knocked up you
don't really love but you like her
you're hanging in there for the kid you
know you gotta settle into that so what
you need to do is uh what you got it
just immediately you got to slow
everything the [ __ ] down and what you
have to do is you got to watch a day
game you got to keep score while you
smoke a cigar you know you get you line
up you get it all ready to go you just
[ __ ] sit there and you like the cigar
about the third inning you know and you
just sit there and you [ __ ] maybe
even on the radio listen to it on the
radio and you just it's like sports yoga
you just have to totally just calm your
mind [ __ ] relax and then slide into
the dog days of baseball right and then
you ride that out for about six weeks
and then all of a sudden it's NFL
preseason all right
and as the preseason comes along you're
excited about football because every
week's excited because they only play 16
games right but baseball is also ramping
up so then when September comes along
it's like April May June with basketball
and hockey because now it's like you're
so excited how [ __ ] NFL football college
football it's coming back I have a
reason to live right and the baseball
race is heating up before you go in with
Joe Buck and all the great October
baseball that's how you do it all right
so these next six weeks after the finals
are over you know I'm telling you I'll
walk you through it on the podcast you
know you pick a couple of alternative
sports maybe you watch a little Roland
Garros a little Wimbledon
you get into Formula One maybe a little
uh MotoGP right I don't want the [ __ ]
you got to do it's night it's not my
business it's none of my business what
time is it nine fifty five let's see if
I can read advertising in five minutes I
don't think I can do it especially when
I got a type of my goddamn password the
family back east kidding um all right
what do we got here
a Love Supreme all right weary uh in
Dodi don't cheat don't talk about how
every man looks better in a suit you
know when I'm checking out a fella I
love boy shorts just like the next guy
but what really turns me on is a nice
sharp looking fella in a suit you know
what I mean grabbed them by his tie all
right endo Geno is making it easy to get
a perfectly tailored suit at an
incredible price you can choose from
hundreds of top quality fabrics and
personalize your suits you [ __ ]
initials on the pocket just the way you
want it don't you build su whether it
works whether it's for work a wedding or
another special occasion endo Tito has
suited up hundreds of thousands of men
and are now the largest made-to-measure
menswear brand in the world world world
world here's how it works
visit a showroom or shop online an
indogene o IND Oh ch Ino calm like the
Indigo Girls if they went to China in
dope t you know pick your fabric I went
to the warehouse I picked out of [ __ ]
su I went with 3-piece I tooked way
moment it's choose your customized
customizations from lapels depletes to
jacket linings and more submit submit
your measurements place your order and
wait for it to arrive in just a few
weeks this week my listeners can get any
premium indogene Oh soup for just $379 a
Tendo Chino calm when entering BRR at
checkout that's 50% off the regular
price
for a made-to-measure premium suit plus
shipping is free
that's Indo Chino comm promo code bar
for any premium suit for three hundred
and seventy nine dollars and free
shipping incredible deal for a suit that
will fit you better than anything off
the rack ever could 9:57 how many more
do i got i got two more to go five for
club yo you like a short [ __ ] this is
the five for club okay looking good
doesn't need to cost a fortune five for
club is revolutionizing the way men stop
at five fold club they found a way to
make a great look great looking clothes
affordable for everyone five fold club
also understands that your time is
extremely valuable why one wasted at the
mall or wandering around in stores each
month they send you a curated box of two
to three items that just means somebody
else picked it out I hate that [ __ ]
word curated if somebody gives a [ __ ]
the [ __ ] does this guy want tank top
said you have [ __ ] tank tops
why wasted why the [ __ ] am i hand-picked
matched the current season and your
style
oh they're calling early oh this is from
Montreal Quebec
[Music]
alright I'll back them in between
interviews I'm in between [ __ ]
interviews here I got on the wrong
[ __ ] headphone alright here we go
back back I got another interview in
four minutes with the vbe
all right let's put the [ __ ] was I
talking about trying to type in my
password this is a mess why would I do
this before I hit [ __ ] said it yeah
there we go there we go oh five folk
club did I finish five folk club they've
been helping men with fashion for over
15 years and shipped over a hundred
thousand men every month Chris Paul in
my Wahlberg used five-fold club if fat
folk club is featured in GQ Vice and in
style among
publications they know what they're
doing so if you don't think that's okay
five-four club will help you what they
know what they're doing so if you don't
also if you don't that's okay
I thought they were getting a little
chip on itself so you don't think that's
okay then [ __ ] you get you goddamn suit
somewhere else five folk club will help
you build your wardrobe one month at a
time because when you look good you feel
good brother than that thing you know
she's on her knees it's a fact of life
you get $120 worth of clothes for just
$60 a month you keep that doesn't make
sense it worth eighty percent of the
time it works 100% of time you can pause
or cancel anytime no commitments and as
a five-fold club member you receive up
to 50% off your items in their online
shop and access to exclusive Members
Only items get a Members Only jacket for
30 bucks free shipping and sighs
exchanges go to five fo club.com right
now and enter your promo code burr and
they'll give you 50% off your first
month's package plus a free pair of
sunglasses that's 50% off your first
package at five foe club spell five-0 no
you are club comm promo code burr 5o
club.com promo code bar all right see so
everybody see so you know I've had funny
feelings I've gotten funny looks
I mean I've even eaten funny smelling
sushi but let me tell you none of those
are as funny as seaso streamings library
of stand-up television and original
content especially not the sushi why
would they try to write comedy for us
let me do a quick rewrite of this you
know I've had a funny feeling in my gut
I've gone down on a funny smelling [ __ ]
you know I've been in a parking lot late
at night and felt funny like you know is
this someone going to [ __ ] cut me up
but nothing compares to watching [ __ ]
six feet under on sea soap
all right maybe I should have gone with
this [ __ ] next please mention the
talking points below I'm going to
mention all of them if you [ __ ] give
them to me again cans over them with see
so you get unlimited access to Cecil
original series next day late night
hilarious stand-up specials binge worthy
classics including forty two seasons of
Saturday Night Live the entire monty
pawn Python catalog the it crowd and
more I don't understand why more people
on watch and see so I mean they got some
[ __ ] every episode of Saturday Night
Live is on there the entire Monty Python
cat I don't know what the [ __ ] it
crowd is but [ __ ] if it's following
those two it's got to be good with Cecil
you get binge worthy classics British
cult comedy original series like Harmon
quest and bajillion dollar properties
not to mention the entire SNL library I
just [ __ ] said I'm supposed to pick
one of these or watch your favorite sets
from comedians like louis c.k Amy [ __ ]
Shuma and Hannibal Buress access see so
content from anywhere at any time using
iOS Android Roku Apple TV Amazon fire TV
stealing cable from your neighbor
Windows or Xbox one ready for the
punchline Cecil is just 399 per month no
joke 399 per month for all the comedy
want anytime anywhere add [ __ ] free
go to see so SE eso calm right now to
sign up for one month for free with the
promo code bird at checkout that see so
calm spelled se ESO calm promo code bar
alright what else did I want to talk
about oh by the way Tiger Woods who was
arrested everybody said was arrested for
for drinking and driving blue at 0.0 0.0
Matt Jesus Christ here's another one
hang on a second hello
and those are two fun interviews I just
talked to a guy who goes by lights
camera Jackson
how do you not love that guy
that is old-school showbiz how do you
ever forget that name lights camera
Jackson alright let me type this in here
your family back east my [ __ ]
password why won't you work for me
why won't you work for me you know it's
funny if somebody has enough time at
some point to [ __ ] splice together
every time me I'm trying to [ __ ] put
together my password yeah by the way
Tiger Woods taiga woo blue is zero point
zero the dude was on pills you don't to
me the level of [ __ ] that that guys get
that guy a Feist his [ __ ] body to
become great ok now his body's breaking
down and everybody's blaming it on the
fact that he cheated on his lay right
that's what did him in his laser-focused
he couldn't block out the fat I the
first two years yeah I'm sure it bugged
him but I mean at some point you move on
right
his body blade said it from the very
beginning they said the way he swings
the club his body's gonna break down at
some point so now look at him now look
at him you know he's trying to come back
he's on all these painkillers he wants
to win another one probably before he
hangs it up and goes to the the Senior
Tour he's doing what he has to do these
[ __ ] drugs that you can get nowadays
are completely out of control when I was
a kid when a drug came out bare or any
of this [ __ ] they didn't have 9000
side-effects what happened was people
used to be in the pharmaceutical
industry got into the [ __ ] FDA and
they're the ones who police the
pharmaceutical companies and those [ __ ]
just waved everything around like a
third-base coach did that lost his
vision right so then they let opiates
into the [ __ ] world now you got a
goddamn heroin epidemic okay
and now Tiger Woods is taking too many
of those [ __ ] things and he pulls
over to the side of the road and
everybody's saying it's because he did
the [ __ ] blond-haired blue-eyed woman
who evidently is a saint
who took his [ __ ] his master's money
bought a giant house not the [ __ ]
thing down to buy something else where
did all that material go where did all
those [ __ ] gold-plated toilets go
they went right to the [ __ ] ocean you
know but she's a victim
I'll give me a break that's it for the
podcast signing off not [ __ ] it with you
um I'm just trying to energy my way
through the last bit of this what else
do I have here to talk about oh you know
who has a great new bits new bit I
produce name is challi Charlie Watts
drummer for The Rolling Stones as a
great new book out that it's just
drummers that influenced him and if
you're a drummer and you're into that
[ __ ] because he's I guess a jazz drummer
at heart he talked about all these
[ __ ] great drummers that I've heard
most of the names and didn't know enough
about him and the fact that he could
break down their styles and what they
did has made me I was already listening
to a lot of that [ __ ] through some of my
drum lessons but really just trying to
listen to the [ __ ] that he's saying it's
a great book
let me let me look it up here I made a
[ __ ] hypest book here you know we've
been trying to get Charlie Watts on this
podcast for a long time I know he
doesn't do a lot of interviews and but I
know he'd want to come on my podcast
I'm joking Charlie Watts book let's see
what we got here jolly
you know the [ __ ] internet works in
like two rooms in my [ __ ] house I
spent all this money like can you get me
the nuclear level [ __ ] Internet so I
can somehow beat out my neighbors and
you know it works for a little while
then that's it really so in Charlie
Watts 10 things you didn't know about
Charlie Watts why no books about Charlie
Watts
you know I'm usually good about from
Charlie Ward books drummers influence
book you know I nailed the John Daly
search the last time come on for [ __ ]
sakes Oh Charlie Watts favorite drummer
so it did come up dude you get it for 12
bucks 12 dollars and 37 cents
whiplash the film that puts the drummer
in the limelight I didn't even tell you
guys how much I [ __ ] hated that movie
I just hated watching somebody getting
berated it's just like [ __ ] quick go
join another band why would you sit
there taking that level of [ __ ] from the
guy and then not to mention the kids
and technique you had to look away when
he was [ __ ] playing real fast he's
making those faces he could just feel
the guy's forearms tighten up this guy
this guy's gonna have carpal tunnel
trying to please this complete [ __ ] you
know and I got to tell you the best
drums from that year was not in that
movie as great as the drums were the
best [ __ ] drums and some of the best
drums I've heard in a movie a mainstream
movie in a long [ __ ] time was that
Michael Keaton movie the [ __ ] was that
movie where he was the former superhero
the bird do you know long I watched that
movie before I realized that was him in
the costume talking to himself
spoiler alert all right Michael Keaton
I'm just gonna write bird and [ __ ] you
spell his name I've only been watching
his movies for 30 [ __ ] years bill
Jesus Christ Michael Keaton bird bird
man yo bird man five-o um who the [ __ ]
is the drummer in that I know I talked
about that before the drums in that
movie are [ __ ] incredible it's like
like that that's just a whole other
level of drumming with that guy is like
he's playing like moods as opposed to
just playing 90 million miles an hour
all over the kid that guy is he's he's
creating peaks and valleys and that was
like a that was literally a movie score
just done with drums I mean how many
people have that level of talent I can
tell you right now I know I don't I
already knew I didn't and for the last
three weeks because I've been so damn
busy I've just been playing like you
know not on a real drum kit you know
little practice pad kit that I was
playing on and I thought I was you know
I thought I was doing something and then
I went down and I played on a real
[ __ ] kit in Jesus Christ everything
that you think he can you can do drops
by like fifty BPMS you know it'd be
basically like if you were just jogging
on a treadmill being like wow man I can
run a 7-minute mile then you go out to
run down the street you don't you forgot
about hills and [ __ ] and all of a sudden
you know you can't run a 7-minute mile
anymore even if
flat flat level okay even if it was flat
level of a sudden you run like a [ __ ]
11 min mile that's what it's like it was
extremely [ __ ] disheartening and I'm
doing the Comedy Jam this weekend up in
San Francisco for cluster fest which is
just completely like one of the biggest
I don't know how they afforded the to
get all of those comedians and bands and
all of that they must add a lot of add
money somebody's doing something to
establish that Comedy Festival going
we're gonna go [ __ ] you know nine
million dollars in the hole to start it
out but uh you might want to go this
year because they're going big well what
a moment forgot before I sign off here
thank you to everybody who's been
watching season two of f is for family
uh got nothing but great reviews you
know there's always a couple of kunti
once what are you going to do but
overall you guys not only like it but
you're saying you think it's even better
than the first season which for the
amount of work that we put in to hear
that kind of feedback you know I know
I'm a jerk a lot that really means a lot
to me so thank you guys for not only
watching it thank you for the people
that took the time to let me know how
much you enjoyed it please let other
people know about it the more other
people know about it the more people
watch it and a better chance we have of
possibly getting a third season and
that's it that's the podcast for this
week have a great weekend you can steer
and here's a little bit of music from
Andrew emili´s and then we'll play a
little half hour some Greatest Hits from
a Thursday or a podcast or whatever from
a Thursday gone by or maybe a Monday
morning I don't know what we're doing
here alright that's not my part of the
podcast all right I'll talk to you on
Monday
all right here this is the longest
[ __ ] revenge story I think I've ever
read let me see if I can see if I can
[ __ ] just I'm gonna blow more read
that one next week when I have the
energy alright questions alright bill uh
I have a question for you I was hoping
you might be able to shine some insight
on this I have this great friend that
that's a girl mistake
um and we get along great and
you have never had any sort of sexual
tension or interest despite her being
attractive alright dude right there you
are either gay or you're an idiot and
I'm not sure I'm giving you some tough
love here
that's a [ __ ] stupid situation to be
involved in that's stupid
alright unless you're using her to
attract other females to get you [ __ ]
late let's see if this is the case I
will continue reading so she has this
smoking hot friend oh there we go that
I'd met a few times and always flirted
with but uh butts just been overall
friendly so this chick calls me up one
night and I'm at the bar at like
midnight and asked if I want to stay up
drinking with her and she come pick me
up so obviously I agree things go very
good and we have a few drinks and flirt
and when I make my move she gets all
upset like I should have known she just
wants to be friends when she calls me up
at midnight to say to stay up drinking
with her alone after the incident the
[ __ ] still has the balls to ask to
sleep over since then I have noticed all
her friends are trying to be my friend
when all I want to do is rail the [ __ ]
out of them bill I was hoping you could
you should you could shine some light on
the situation and help me out yeah dude
never have a friend as a as a female you
know you always got to be [ __ ] them
that's the only reason to be around him
you know I know that sounds really
sexist but you know I just I'm speaking
from me there's no [ __ ] point in
hanging out with that level of
frustration if you're not having sex
with them and if they're actually like a
good friend and that's the one that you
should I mean that's the ultimate if
you're banging them and they're also a
great friend that's the one you marry
because you got a connection there right
but if you just I mean that they're
using you as like a live teddy bear and
yeah the next time they call up just be
like no I'm like I'm not I can't hang
out tonight why what are you doing I'm
gonna go out and try to get some
ask tonight I know I'm not getting any
from you and it's frustrating because
you're hot and I want to bend you over
every piece of [ __ ] furniture in my
apartment oh yeah I can't believe you
said that yeah well I just did are you
gonna come over here and [ __ ] me well
then great I have to go
let me fill mean I'm not being mean I'm
being honest okay yeah many times I've
jerked off to you it's [ __ ] and it's
annoying that you just you just I'm
telling you like that's a little
aggressive but that's what you have to
start doing he just have to be
straightforward and honest and don't do
it like I just said it do if do it how
you can do it and pull it off and you
just say it like that just feel I want
to go out I want try to get laid tonight
alright and I go out with you and you're
not [ __ ] me and then other girls see
me with you and they think that I am
[ __ ] you which I'm not and I end up
going home dry humping my futon you know
and it's really [ __ ] with my
self-esteem okay so that's it so
basically what are you saying you're
saying that um if I don't suck your [ __ ]
you know I hang out with me yes that is
what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying your
conversations are awful you know I'm
sure they're interesting to other
females but not to me I don't want to I
don't want to talk about that [ __ ] I can
give a [ __ ] about the hills the OSI the
ocean or whatever the [ __ ] I was stupid
show you well I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] I want to [ __ ] you
okay this world said right that you
noticed you ever see will watch the
World Series of Poker when you go all-in
that's what you do just say what the
[ __ ] you want to do you push all your
chips in then you stand up and you start
walking around you wait for that next
card to drop and see what the [ __ ]
happens yeah dude that's my advice get
out of that whole circle of anything a
big teddy bear [ __ ] that [ __ ] that all
right you're not a teddy bear
well you are one right now you got to
stop being that guy so [ __ ] all of them
go uh where your guy friends what are
they doing go hang out with them go get
a [ __ ] wingman get yourself back in
the game and go out there talk some [ __ ]
hit on some girl you don't give a [ __ ]
about so you can practice not giving a
[ __ ] and just say a bunch of [ __ ] that
you would never see
a to some girl that you gave a [ __ ]
about and because you don't give a [ __ ]
if the girl says no start with that you
know always wear a condom and and that's
it that's what I would do that's what I
should have done I didn't I just have
that knowledge now because I'm [ __ ]
have I been the FINA so I was never the
friend but I was definitely the
douchebag
I was definitely that the not even
pussy-whipped wasn't even pussy-whipped
was just I couldn't [ __ ] speak up for
myself I was afraid of having a
confrontation and then by the time I had
the final confrontation I was like wow
it was like [ __ ] a year with the [ __ ]
we broke up but that's a whole nother
stories hey what's up everybody it's
bill burr this is the Monday morning
podcast that I'm recording for the third
time this week praying and hoping
against hope that gks will actually
upload this one because I've already
spent 90 minutes doing podcast this week
so anyways if you're hearing this it
means I successfully uploaded it so
there's no sense complaining unlike the
rest of the people in my [ __ ] life
you know you ever just have one of those
weeks where everyone's just bitching at
you that's what I got you know
that's what I'm dealing with right now
like today's my girlfriend's birthday
and she's she was [ __ ] pissed at me
she went absolutely psycho on me this
morning
you know it had nothing to do with me
had nothing to [ __ ] do with me you
know I gave her a piece of cake last
night right at midnight sang her happy
birthday cuz technically it was a
birthday I gave her a pre birthday slice
of cake and then I gave her a bag of
Fritos with a little bow on it right
just being a silly jackass like that's
all you're getting for your birthday
right and everything was going great I
was a big sweetheart and then I woke up
this morning and made the mistake of
telling her that I had made a dinner
reservation yet and then she starts
flipping out acting like I'm just
throwing her goddamn birthday together
when I gave her a pre birthday [ __ ]
slice of birthday cake you know starts
flipping out I mean I don't know why she
was flipping out it's like it's [ __ ]
Tuesday it's a Tuesday it's not a
holiday this who the [ __ ] is going out
tonight
June 2nd oh [ __ ] was it Cinco de Mayo
you know is it for some [ __ ] New
Zealand holiday that I don't know about
there's gonna be plenty of [ __ ]
reservations and lo and behold after she
flips out you know screaming at me right
so all my neighbors think that I'm
beating her women love doing that [ __ ]
they just put on this big [ __ ] show
right
and then afterwards they just gone sorry
I got a little crazy I don't know and I
was thinking I just you don't hate me do
you you forgive me they do that [ __ ]
right meanwhile you know your neighbors
don't hear that part they don't hear the
part where they sort of say really
quietly that they flipped out for no
[ __ ] reason you know all they heard
was - screaming - yelling so now I'm
gonna get the looks today I'm gonna go
down to the garage you know like it's
the 1920s like I should be come walking
out with like a [ __ ] wife beater you
know as I reattached the belt to my
pants
[Laughter]
so this what happens right I end up
calling up this [ __ ] restaurant this
is not one of the nicest steak houses
out here and la I call him up I said hey
I'd like a reservation for two people
like okay sir what time would you like I
said how about eight I can't do anything
at eight how about 8:30 and I said you
know what sweetheart that would be
perfect and she said okay and that was
it
that's all I had to [ __ ] do but for
some reason because I didn't do that
before her birthday that means that I
don't give a [ __ ] that's how [ __ ]
nuts women are she absolute she actually
flipped out on me at 10 o'clock in the
morning on her birthday she didn't give
me a chance to [ __ ] the day up she did a
preemptive strike even though I gave her
a pre birthday slice of cake
I sang happy birthday - shut her eyes I
put I put out the lights I lit a candle
I came in I sang happy birthday and I
gave her a bag of Fritos which is
[ __ ] ridiculous and silly it was
great and tonight she's getting the real
gift if you know what I mean
Oh umm you know so it's one of those
deals where I'm laying in bed and then
all of a sudden she uh it's just [ __ ]
ridiculous you know but I didn't back
down I didn't back down
you know actually when she really got
mad why she started flipping out it's
because she when she was screaming at me
I was laughing you know I don't know if
any other guy out there has that problem
you ever haven't you like when your
girlfriend starts yelling at you your
first instinct is just to start laughing
I don't know why every time my girl
yells at me I instantly feel like I'm in
school again and I'm like in second
grade and I'm getting yelled at and it's
just and my friends are laughing at me
that's that's what I feel like I feel
ridiculous I guess that's what it is
when a woman yells at me I always feel
ridiculous
you know what a guy yells at me I get
mad because I think I'll [ __ ] this guy's
going to beat the [ __ ] out of me so you
got to get into that energy
but when a girl woman is just today
[ __ ] screech what are you supposed to
do you know I'm not gonna yell back at
you you're a woman I don't want to feel
like a bully we're not gonna get
physical you're a woman you know it's
stupid stop yelling that [ __ ]
high-pitched voice you sound like a
[ __ ] like Mickey Mouse sit down relax
collect your thoughts make a list if you
have to tell me why you're upset you
know but don't just sit there [ __ ]
yelling at me like you just took a hit
off a helium balloon because it just
sounds hilarious especially when I
haven't done anything wrong
and I got a great [ __ ] gift this year
that's what was killing me that actually
actually had that moment during the
fight where I said you want you gift
fine and I went out and I'd pull that
that's already wrapped with the bow on
it
you know sitting there acting like I'm
not [ __ ] prepared there's your
[ __ ] present BAM wrapped with a
[ __ ] bow on it
Jesus everybody giving me [ __ ] remember
last week when I called that woman a
douchebag remembered the douchebag of
the week last week because she was givin
me [ __ ] once again a female surprise
surprise was giving me [ __ ] that when I
read the underrated overrated or the
questions people have
I wouldn't say what sex they were and
she somehow found out a way to kind of I
don't know make me look like I was some
chauvinist that I guess she felt if it
was a good question I credited a guy and
you know it's a free podcast all right
stop being so [ __ ] kunti so she
became douche bag of the week so
evidently she didn't like it
and what does she do she sends me an
email his email she sends me a bill it's
nice that you named me douche bag of the
week I don't really give a [ __ ] because
I always mean what I write I don't know
what that means because I always mean
what I write oh really what are the rest
of us just faking it we're just joking
around but not you you're so [ __ ]
serious
anyways evidently this psycho is a new
segment this is site I can't I can't
figure out this is love letter of the
week or psycho of the week I don't know
you guys name it I don't give a [ __ ] so
anyways she goes I don't really give a
[ __ ] because I always mean what I write
and it seems you just talking [ __ ] about
two things that I wrote that seemed
[ __ ] no I was talking about your
entire email
don't try to knock it down alright
continuing here she goes call me a [ __ ]
but I really don't give a [ __ ]
you've read a lot of my comments
previously and agreed with them or had a
good response to them I'm clearly fixing
her sentences because she doesn't know
how to write here but it's nice that you
will consider telling the gender of the
person who could who the comments are
from and I know you have a shitload of
people who listen to your podcast but I
got you some more since my friends who
heard the podcast thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious
and then they started listening to you
so you really should be thanking me
isn't this just typical this is just all
gonna be woman bashing this week isn't
this just typical of a [ __ ] female
you know what I mean she's getting
something every week every week that is
free and she still found a way to [ __ ]
about it okay and then when I call her
out for being a douchebag now she's
actually trying to make me feel guilty
you know I just you know you call me a
douche bag you know whatever I mean just
even though I got a whole bunch of
friends to listen to I mean probably
should be thanking me but you know
that's okay shut up just shy swear to
God why can't just slap women you know
back in the day how great did that feel
you know you have on the wife beater the
wind blowing through your armpit hair is
you just crack
I know it's evil I don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] all you guys don't give a [ __ ] this
is the rest of her email okay before you
think I'm an [ __ ] this is what she
wrote this is actually so psychotic it's
hilarious
she writes and yeah I do know that the
name shows up on the email even if I
don't sign it but you just make it seem
like you that much of a [ __ ] to notice
that's literally what she wrote and then
she wrote you're over 40 and have the
vocabulary of a seventh grader your is
spelled Y oh you are
all right for all you morons out there
your while you are is possessive meaning
like that's your shirt okay if you're
saying you're over 40 that's you are
okay so that means if you're going to
say you're it's an apostrophe why oh you
apostrophe re so if you're a dumb [ __ ]
like this woman if you don't know the
next time you go to write you're just
stop and see if you are would still fit
alright like you're over 40 you are over
40 okay right there you know you got to
use the apostrophe as as opposed to
saying you're over 40 so what is over do
I own over you dumb [ __ ] but I do have
the vocabulary of a seventh-grader but
you know something you have the [ __ ]
vocabulary third-grader alright you're
over 40 and you have the vocabulary of a
seventh-grader you can't recognize real
words how hilarious is this and she's
misspelling stuff you started when you
read and I hope your dog outlives you
and you die lonely because of your
inability to commit and therefore never
achieve the comedic fame of the great
George Carlin so Simon Says go [ __ ]
yourself since it sounds like you have
major brain damage alright sweetheart
I'm really going to try to help you out
here okay if you hope that my dog
outlives me and then you say and then I
die lonely okay if I'm going to die
before my dog mathematically the [ __ ]
dog is still going to be there so how am
I going to be lonely you know the dog
would have to
I first are run away so what you should
say is I hope your dog outlives you then
runs away and then you die by yourself
as opposed to saying I hope your dog
outlives you when you die lonely now I
would die before my dog and be sitting
there licking my face in my last few
pathetic moments and then evidently
because of my inability to commit to a
relationship I'll never achieve the
comedic fame of George Carlin oh that
totally makes sense it has nothing to do
with the fact that I wasn't blessed with
his gifts as a comedian you know all you
have to do to be as good as George
Carlin is just commit to a relationship
to some psycho [ __ ] chick like you
all right lady
these are podcasts these are jokes when
I call somebody a douchebag I'm just
[ __ ] around so don't take it
seriously but if you want to you and
your friends can go [ __ ] yourselves and
go listen to another podcast all right
stop trying to threaten me like you're
gonna take podcast listener there's
listeners away I don't give a [ __ ] this
is free we're going to take away
advertising dollars from me I don't give
a [ __ ] [ __ ] you and your friends I hope
you're all listening it together [ __ ]
all of you look around the room look
into each one of your eyes I'm saying
[ __ ] all of you it was funny is your
friends are probably laughing at you
right now going you know what she is she
is kind of a [ __ ] she really is like
that she does have a tendency I know I
shouldn't use that word but I'm serious
she is she can be real [ __ ] II sometimes
and she has a tendency to exaggerate
things that aren't really happening at
factor in her alright so that's the
first hate mail so I figured you know
when I seek out I'll try to find some
other hate mail here's one that I got on
YouTube
this is a nice one basically I there's a
clip on there from me from about eight
years ago which will obviously notice
because I'm skinnier and have a full
head of hair and I'm doing this bit
about joining the military saying how
you know when you watch the commercials
for the military it makes you want to
join you know they make it look like
everybody gets their own jet everybody's
driving a tank
everyone's doing some Top Gun [ __ ]
everyone's having a you know you're a
[ __ ] Navy SEAL you get your face
painted and you're clinging to that raft
and you're coming up out of the water
like [ __ ] Rambo disappearing into the
mud and [ __ ] that's what they make you
look like right
but what they don't show is all the
other jobs that you know you go in there
and you think you're going to be like
you know Tom Cruise oh my god my dog
just farted Jesus Christ Cleo you know
could you at least like you know what
kills me about this dog when it farts is
it doesn't have the decency that [ __ ]
kind of make a face like yeah that was
me sorry about that
she just lays here good lord
at least it's silent you know it's the
worse than when you have a dog that
farts like a person never been over
somebody's house and the dogs in a
corner they just going it's like really
anyways so that was the bit so the bit
is yeah you'd see the commercial and you
sign up you thinking yeah I'm going to
be like Tom Cruise and Top Gun and then
you show up and you end up being that
guy you know when the jet takes off you
just like point in the same direction
that the Jets going or they give you
those those orange glow sticks from a
rave you know when the plane comes in
you're that guy you put the air and the
tires on the jet you know
you join the next thing you know you're
standing there with like a camouflage
weed whacker when we gave man yeah that
was a joke okay simple joke I actually
did the joke at a military base and I
also did it at one of the VA hospitals
and it [ __ ] killed you know what I
mean so this guy of course has to go all
Fox News on YouTube and this is what he
writes is actually kind of funny he
writes you ungrateful [ __ ] and then he
puts in quotes if you're dumb enough to
join the military
dot-dot-dot which is classic of somebody
who wants to take a joke seriously is
they don't write the whole joke is they
just take not even a sentence they just
take a part of a sentence okay so he
writes if you dumb enough to join the
military dot and then he writes in
capital letters fact fact is if it
wasn't for the bravery of the American
servicemen and the American spirit
throughout history I like the American
spirit what do you mean chicks who go to
a [ __ ] bake sale anyways you wouldn't
even get you wouldn't even have the
right to mock those sacrifices which
have been made for you and if you did
you would probably be doing it
germán so respect your American
servicemen because it is him in which
you owe your freedoms to take to that
what people came you know half the time
people think I'm a [ __ ] because people
can't even write a sentence because it
is him in which you owe your freedoms to
that you take so foolishly for granted
that's word-for-word appreciate the
sacrifices of other you coward you know
at what point did I make fun of
servicemen I didn't I was making fun of
the how [ __ ] whatever you know
something if you guys want to take job
seriously I don't give a [ __ ] and I'm
really sick of that hacky thing where
someone goes you know and they did it
for you and if you didn't you'd be
speaking German right now that's how
dumb people are you know that just used
to say that you'd be speaking German
right now is a hacky [ __ ] reference
you're just saying that because you
heard someone else say it you know why
wouldn't I be speaking like I was from
England why wouldn't I be speaking
Spanish right now you know we did fight
other countries mexican-american war how
come that one never gets brought up how
can I wouldn't be speaking Korean I mean
granted they weren't over here but you
know what I'm saying I'm so sick of
[ __ ] idiots who speak in sound bites
like everyone who like makes fun of
France yeah we [ __ ] saved your ass
World War two you [ __ ] [ __ ] read a
history book we were paying them back
for saving our ass with England yet dumb
[ __ ] so now we're even
alright whatever look at me I'm getting
all upset here because people are morons
alright let's let's move on to Silvia
let's let's get to some information here
for the week alright um last week I was
all here's ago and last week I was at
teasing firefighters and I was talking
about how you know 20 truck show up to
every fire why does that happen how much
of those trucks cost and volunteer
firefighter wrote in he said pop it up
ah duh
yes how much fire trucks cost fire
engines which put the water out oh wait
put the water out fire engines which put
water out I think I'm Dyslexic
typically run between 300,000 and
$600,000 fire trucks also called ladder
trucks run between 400,000 and 800,000
the two main differences between the low
and high numbers is the make of the
truck and the equipment it comes with a
fire engine with all the hoses added on
and the breathing apparatus is more
expensive than without all right well
here's a question I have with for you
you say the make of the truck so I guess
what Mack truck that's a reputable brand
as opposed to what a high-end a fire
truck I guess that's what it is I don't
know what the [ __ ] they are but anyways
you asked us you asked why so many
pieces of apparatus show up to a call
there are a few reasons for this
sometimes its manpower in my case we
have three fire companies consisting of
six pieces of apparatus since we
volunteer there may not be enough
volunteers in town at any one time so
all three companies get banged out
banged out equals called out in
firefighting terms typically at least
four pieces show up for a call this
allows us to have all the equipment we
need at the scene sometimes you just
never know what you're going to need
alright fair enough
but perhaps the best reason this is
great here but perhaps the best reason
is that sometimes we are called for what
amounts to be in the end absolutely
nothing about six months ago my pager
went off your pager Jesus Christ dude is
your fire truck pulled by a couple of
horses who the [ __ ] still has a picture
I know he's gonna write back actually
two special [ __ ] 9/11 pager four
firemen I write I'm a [ __ ] I get it
alright about six months ago my pager
went off for for a working house fire at
2:00 a.m. I jumped awake and flew down
to the firehouse we got on the scene we
saw no smoke or flames in speaking with
the residents they had just woke up and
saw a reflection in their mirror that
they thought was a fire so here's all
six of our apparatus showing up for
absolutely nothing or the time we called
for the four lightning hit lightning
hitting a house on a clear summer night
the
woman heard something and thought it was
lightning hitting her house people are
[ __ ] idiots all over hope that helps
and even though I am a firefighter your
firefighter jokes were funny see there's
a cool guy you see there sweetheart
even though he's a firefighter he sees
the joke he realizes I'm just telling
jokes all right there you go people how
we learned something this week all right
you want to learn something else I'm
gonna wrap up this [ __ ] podcast I
know it's really short this week but at
the what I don't understand what the
point of me keep babbling for [ __ ] 15
minutes if gks won't upload the files
all right here's some computer tips for
the week here's some computer tips on
web searching all right bill when you
want to find something that uh that you
are google it what that makes no sense
all right when you google use the plus
and the minus signs to find the [ __ ] you
want to this how it works if you want to
search something with a plus in front of
it then it will have to contain the word
and if you want to put a minus in front
of it that will remove the word from the
listing so basically put the plus in
front of the word that you're searching
that you want to find and a minus in
front of the one that you don't want for
example I want to see how many sites
have bill burr on it while limit while
eliminating bill burr from from the
search so you would Google the plus sign
plus my name bill then the plus sign and
then you write burr - billboard.com
and the results will will show sites
that can have content with bill burr on
it and not include billboard.com huh
isn't that interesting
I didn't know that [ __ ] and he said I'm
listed on seven hundred thousand seven
hundred six thousand web pages not
including my website seven hundred and
six thousand web sites have my name on
it and I still can't sell out the third
show on Saturday night what the [ __ ] is
going on all right if you find some [ __ ]
out like if you want to find some [ __ ]
out like to do to you I can't read what
you guys write if you want to find some
[ __ ]
like to you do when you are on what I
can't even paraphrase that
you want to find some [ __ ] out like -
you do now like you do when you're on
the podcast all right you had an extra
word in there dude if you want to find
some [ __ ] out like you do when you're on
the podcast use the above option the
plus minus or
or use quotes
wanted to find the names of female
serial killers a few weeks ago just put
quotes around a phrase and it will only
show sites that contain all phrases okay
I get it you know like you guys ever go
to search something and you're like
you'll just write female serial killers
and then a bunch of hits will come up
and you have a bunch that just say
female and a bunch that will just say
serial and other one will just say
killers or whatever I guess if you put
quotes around it that puts it all
together you know what that's very
helpful I know this part of the podcast
isn't that funny but god damn it you
know you got to learn something here all
right I should have got some water here
my [ __ ] mouth is dry as hell alright
let's wrap up the podcast here this is
the serial killer topic bill if you want
to be a serial killer and use the best
weapon you have to use ice if you stab
someone with a icicle or beat someone to
death with ice then it melts and you
have no murder weapon or fingerprints no
DNA or fingerprint problems oh yeah that
guy who that talked about tracking you
down with the type of soil where it was
located the type of wood used and all
that [ __ ] is exactly that
[ __ ] they watched too many show CSI
does not do that [ __ ] I know dude we all
knew he was just [ __ ] around he was
making fun of how when you watch those
shows alright what else do we got here
question Bill you say that you play the
drums if you could play the drums in any
band living or dead for one show one
night only in any city in the world who
would you play and in what city [ __ ] um
Jesus Christ it would either be Led
Zeppelin
you know what's funny is I think I would
have a better better chance faking what
John Bonham does than what Phil Rudd
does in ac/dc what Phil Rudd does is so
[ __ ] difficult if you play drums to
just sit there going boom crack boom
crack for [ __ ] two hours straight
yeah I think I would play I would play
with Led Zeppelin I do it in England at
Royal Albert Hall and I would and I
would play on that that the Ludwig that
maple drum kit that he played either
that or his green Sparkle kit I don't
like the Vista Vista light kit he had or
the the stainless steel when I like the
first two ones that he had I play on
either one of those and somehow I would
sound as good as can I can I can I have
that as part of the fantasy that I would
actually sound as good as he would sound
you know that's what I would do and then
I get [ __ ] some 1969 groupie [ __ ]
afterwards all right next question bill
would you rather be respected be a
respected comedian who never makes it
really big like so and so and so and so
I'm not going to name the names he named
to people who are millionaires playing
theatres but I guess who can still walk
down the street he said or would you
rather be a one-trick pony like blah
blah blah who has written one
catchphrase to fame and fortune and has
more cash than he can ever spend oh no
I'd much rather be respected by my peers
without a [ __ ] doubt without a doubt
I would uh you know you can become a
really big comedian and not necessarily
be super fun like that's the great thing
about entertainment is you it's easy to
become I can't say it's easy but you can
become a millionaire and still not be
famous you know what I'm saying and I
always use this example like that sitcom
Caroline in the city they actually made
it to syndication and the entire cast
could walk by me on walking down the
street and I wouldn't recognize any of
them so I would you know dude you're a
millionaire how much [ __ ] money do
you need and I also think the more I
look at these people being super super
famous is for I just doesn't look like a
good time to me you know I think I
but I want to be a millionaire who has
notoriety which means maybe two three
times a month somebody goes hey you're
that comedian I really like what you do
and they thanks a lot then I go back to
eating my omelette I'd rather do that
then [ __ ] I don't know you know I
don't I don't ever want to [ __ ] have
to step out of a limo with no panties on
you know what I mean just so I can
maintain Fame at that [ __ ] level once
you think that what do you think that
that would be miserable I mean other
than when you're at the [ __ ] Celtics
game and you have courtside seats in
that moment that's [ __ ] awesome you
know what I mean I've always used this
analogy but it's someday at some point
you're gonna have to [ __ ] blow out a
bathroom in public and you don't want to
be famous at that point you know you
just want to be like dude you can't some
[ __ ] guy just blew you don't want a
bill bird just blew out the bathroom
they literally put a [ __ ] name to it
it's brutal all right overrated
underrated really quickly overrated beer
with the lime already in it no joke it
just tastes [ __ ] gross um what else
do I got here I'm sorry this is really
[ __ ] unraveling here I just I I've
done I've done this too many times this
[ __ ] week I don't like I've lost my
passion
like if Pau Gasol was doing a [ __ ]
podcast this is what it would sound like
right now you know and I'd be thump in
my chest acting like I'm giving you
entertainment right now and I'm not you
know that's what I'm going to end with
this week what do we got here I'm 28
minutes in good I'll keep it under 30
minutes I'm going to end with this
prediction I think Orlando is going to
beat the Lakers and I think they think
they're going to beat him in six games
because they don't have anybody to stop
Dwight Howard and I think Turk Alou is I
don't know I think that guy's going to
get enough points and then they got that
other guy in the number two or is he the
point guard I don't know [ __ ] about
basketball I just [ __ ] hate the
Lakers so I'm gonna go out on a limb
here with no money down or nothing I'm
not going out on a limb I just I just
think I got a feeling I got a [ __ ]
feeling all right I think Van Gundy is
gonna out he's gonna out coach Phil
Jackson Phil Jackson he's making home
videos with his girlfriend
new hot young girlfriend on his way to
the Staples Center every night there
soft that [ __ ] soft all they have is
Kobe Kobe's the [ __ ] I love Kobe but I
think his teammates are scared of him I
think they're scared to [ __ ] up around
him they're scared to disappoint him and
they just get freaked out and they just
pass him the ball that's what I think is
going to happen Pau Gasol gets the most
quietest 15 [ __ ] rebounds and the
quietest 20 points a game I think he's
going to he's going to take a [ __ ]
Dwight Howard elbow to his bearded chops
sometime in Game two and the Orlando is
going to win Game two they got three in
a row in Orlando they're gonna win two
out of three and then they're gonna come
back and they're gonna beat the
Heartless Lakers in the Staples Center
Game six what the [ __ ] do you guys think
about that huh you like that one you
know what do you guys think about the
two three two playoff format I think
it's [ __ ] I think they give the
advantage to the weaker team because the
Lakers should have home-court right and
I don't think they do with a 232 format
because when it's two three - the
pressure is on the home team for the
first two games right if it was two two
one one one like they do used to do back
in the back of the day you open the
first two games
the pressure is are on Orlando to steal
one now when it's two three - the
pressures on the Lakers they have to win
both of those [ __ ] games
they can't go 1-1 and then have to play
three [ __ ] games in Orlando right my
out of my mind this is all getting
boring well I don't give a [ __ ] because
this is my third one this week listening
to my goddamn mouth is dry so anyways I
might have do another podcast this week
because I might have a very special
announcement of something that I might
be doing next week that might be on
television how you like that I'm leaving
you with a little cliffhanger and with
that I don't have any gigs until the
third week in July when I'm going to be
at the Comedy Works in Denver why is
that I booked a very small part in a
very big movie and I don't know I'm
shooting like five six days on it but
they had to clear out my spec my
schedule because they're working around
famous people schedule so I'm low man on
the totem pole so I gladly cleared out
my spec my schedule so I'll let you know
what the name of the movie is and all
that type of [ __ ] when in fact I know
that I haven't been cut out of it
how's that all right and that's the very
short very succinct Monday morning
podcast this week the third [ __ ] time
I'm praying to God that this thing is
going to actually get published alright
you guys have a good week and thanks to
everybody who came out to the Improv a
couple weekends ago out here in
Hollywood all right that's it take it
easy take it easy